c'était vraiment très émouvant
c'est vaste qu'elle m'a fait vous
remarquerez plus jamais normalement
votre jambe est trop abîmé
on ne peut rien faire désolé il n'y a
rien à faire on peut pas faire miracle
voilà ce que l'on m'a dit un jour
j'avais 14 ans et pourtant je suis là ce
soir
debout devant vous quelques années après
un certain nombre d'années après pour
être tout à fait honnête mais je vais
vous montrer que parfois on peut rendre
l'impossible possible on peut
littéralement faire des miracles
certains d'entre vous trouveront
peut-être cela un petit peu présomptueux
mais si j'ai pu redonner du courage ou
un peu d'espoir à une seule personne
présente ici j'aurais été utile c'est
impossible que vous remarcher vous venez
d'être condamné à une vie de handicap de
douleur et de souffrance vous pourrez
plus jamais courir dans ces marchés
le long d'une plage sur le sable
portrait une canne puis deux c'était
tellement injuste 14 ans c'est l'âge
tout est possible et puis surtout
j'étais ce qu'on appelle alors un espoir
du sport français
j'étais cavalière de saut d'obstacles
pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas un
sport merveilleux l'équitation où on est
en harmonie sur une bête 600 kg qui vole
au dessus des obstacles on défie la
gravité on est soi-même en équilibre
au-dessus de l'animal un certain moment
on vole presque en face à ces camps tout
se passe bien parce que la beauté de ce
sport c'est aussi sa dangerosité
vous êtes quand même sur un animal de
600 kg quelle idée franchement c'est un
peu hasardeuse et puis parfois en tout
cas c'est ce qui m'est arrivé un grain
de sable vient enrayer la machine
mon cheval a foncé pas très droit sur
l'obstacle qui l'avait pas visible
le mans l'intention de le sauter j'ai
réussi à dévier sa course mais pas assez
je les prie de plein fouet
rien de grave rassurez-vous juste une
cheville cassée
sauf qu'au bout de quelques mois au lieu
de remarcher
j'avais toujours très mal la douleur
remontée le long de ma jambe
c'est comme si mon pied se ronger de
l'intérieur j'ai alors passé plusieurs
radios d imagerie par résonance
magnétique
j'ai eu la cheville plus photographiés
qu'un grand mannequin sa grande époque
on est monté à la capitale comme on dit
voir les meilleurs chirurgiens
orthopédiques et puis le verdict est
tombé maladie dégénérative
on ne sait pas réparer ce qui est
détruit et on peut pas enrayé un
processus de destruction ya rien à faire
les meilleurs chirurgie orthopédique
français l'avait dit ça devait donc
forcément être vrai il fallait accepter
accepte accepte la réalité ça être
adulte la leçon était quand même un
petit peu douloureuse à mon sens d'un
coup du jour au lendemain
jeune espoir du sport qui faisait la
fierté de tous j'ai été bombardés dans
un lycée avec des jeunes gens qui
avaient des préoccupations de leur âge
tout à fait normal et moi je me sentais
tellement inadaptée dans cette réalité
là j'avais perdu le contact avec
l'animal avec la nature avec mon
instinct
j'avais perdu tout ce qui faisait ma
valeur mon savoir faire je savais
littéralement rien faire j'ai quand même
passé mon bac sans trop de conviction et
puis la situation s'est empirée
à chaque pas que je faisais chaque fois
que je poser le pied par terre
j'avais si mal que j'avais envie
d'hurler du coup je rester enfermée chez
moi je mangeais un peu trop je dormais
franchement pas assez et puis c'était
tout et le pire c'est que c'était censé
être les plus belles années de ma vie
les autres s'amusent et vivait beaucoup
de choses et moi je restais là et je me
disais ça peut pas être ça la réalité ça
va pas être ça ma vie
quand même qui va se passer quelque
chose et j'étais du coup fini par vivre
enfermé entre quatre murs j'étais dans
une spirale de l'échec personnel
pourquoi j'allais pas mourir j'étais pas
en fauteuil
il ya des gens qui vivent des choses
bien pires tout de même oui mais voilà
j'avais accepté ce mode impossible je
l'avais intégrer d'autres me l'avait
imposé et il avait mis une limite à mon
existence
c'était impossible que je remarche
j'avais fini par accepter de le penser
et un jour lorsque j'ai réalisé que la
nuit avant d'aller aux toilettes
j'attendais au moins une heure parce que
la perspective de la douleur pour y
aller était trop forte
j'ai réalisé que j'avais pas vivre comme
ça j'étais monté très haut
grâce à mes chevaux puis j'étais tombé
très bas mais qu'est ce qui m'empêchait
réellement me relever est ce que c'était
ma she 90% mon corps était quand même
toujours valide ou est-ce que c'était
uniquement ce mot impossible qu'ils
avaient dicté ma vie à ce moment là j'ai
décidé que les médecins avaient tort oui
rien que ça
quel homme peut vous dire vous ne
marcherait jamais je me suis dit ce
qu'il me dit est vrai au moment où il le
dit et à l'endroit où il le dit et ce
qu'il peut me garantir que demain dans 1
an dans cinq ans ou dans dix personnes
aura trouver les moyens de guérir ma
lésion non et ce qu'il me dit est vrai
aussi là où il le dit et ce qu'il a
vraiment fait le tour de la planète et
ce qu il est sûr que nulle part ailleurs
quelqu'un n'a pas la solution à mon
problème
j'en doute non cette pensée m'a libéré
si ce type là à tort ça veut dire que
c'est pas impossible que je remarche à
jour je vais lui donner tort
j'ai commencé du coup à me renseigner et
analysé vraiment quel était mon problème
l'analyse c'est toujours le début de la
solution
j'ai commencé à apprendre à lire les
imageries médicales pour décrypter le
problème
j'ai commencé à apprendre le langage des
médecins pour mieux comprendre ma
pathologie
j'ai appris l'anglais aussi pour pouvoir
mieux m'exprimer j'ai étudié toutes les
dernières innovations en termes de
chirurgie j'ai lu toutes les études qui
était publié
et j'ai contacté tous ceux qui avaient
les meilleurs résultats
j'ai contacté des oeuvres au japon qui
m'ont proposé des prothèses en corail
des australiens qui vous proposer du
cartilage de requin
les allemands eux c'était toujours dû
faire bien solide je vous cache pas que
j'ai fait plusieurs essais sans
forcément beaucoup de réussite
il ya eu beaucoup de centres de
rééducation et beaucoup d'échecs
et puis un jour à mes 27 ans je les
trouvais j'ai trouvé celui qui sur la
planète pratiqué l'opération parfaite
pour moi je les ai contactés au
téléphone et m'a dit je peux pas vous
garantir que ça va marcher mais c'est
possible et ça l'était dans mon pays
j'étais condamné dans un autre pays
il y avait une solution et grâce à
internet tout simplement j'ai pu avoir
accès à la connaissance qui me
permettait de le trouver et au bout de
quelques mois après cette intervention
j'avais 28 ans pour la première fois
depuis mes 14 ans j'ai posé le pied par
terre sans souffrir sans grimacer
c'était miraculeux aussi miraculeux que
la hauteur des chaussures je porte ce
soir vraiment sauf qu'en fait tu savais
rien de miraculeux
c'est tout simplement très pragmatique
ce que j'ai fait j'avais juste une
alternative continuer à m'apitoyer sur
mon sort et en vouloir au monde entier
pour ce qui m'était arrivé cette
injustice ou alors me relever ce qui est
dur dans ces cas là c'est qu'il faut se
relever tout seul même si l'on est très
entourée même si notre nos proches nous
m
ils sont démunis ne peuvent pas nous
aider ça va aller nous distille mais non
ça va pas aller tout seul c'est ça qui
est difficile
il va falloir accepter cette solitude il
va falloir aller chercher en soi
la clé pour sortir de cette pièce fermée
dans laquelle la maladie ou un trauma
vous à enfermer
même si ça fait mal même si ça fait peur
même si on a envie de s'écrouler en
sanglots ou d'être pris dans les bras
pour juste tout oublier et une fois que
ça a été fait vraiment j'ai pu être
libéré j'ai pu remonter à cheval et
surtout en retrouvant les chevaux j'ai
réalisé que j'avais eu cette chance-là
de découdre découvrir et être habitué
aux sports de compétition
la compétition m'a appris le goût de
l'effort le doute la remise en question
et puis le goût de la victoire aussi et
puis j'ai eu une deuxième chance quand
même c'est de faire des études de
philosophie de questionner le monde
remettre en cause les certitudes et
d'apprendre à penser par moi même 11
pensé par toi même dit emmanuel kant
c'était devenu mon philosophe préféré et
il dit une autre chose il apprend à
faire la distinction entre désir et et
vouloir quand on désire quelque chose
c'est qu'on a envie d'une chose
lorsqu'on veut quelque chose c'est la
rationalité la raison qui se met en
branle
quand je veux rationnellement atteindre
un but je dois vouloir toutes les étapes
qui vont me permettre d'y arriver
qui veut la fin veut les moyens dit
quand si je veux aller de a jusqu à eux
je dois vouloir passer par b par ses
parts dès ainsi de suite
est ce que j'avais vraiment envie de
marcher ou est ce que je voulais
vraiment remarcher ça c'était la
véritable question est la véritable
question qu'il faut se poser pour y
arriver c'est qu'elle est l'impossible
que j'ai intégré qui a posé une limite à
mon existence et qui me fait souffrir
est ce que c'est je ne peux pas
démissionné
trouver un meilleur emploi avec un
patron non abusif est ce que c'est on
peut pas m'aimer réellement pour ce que
je suis c'est impossible que je guérisse
retrouvez c'est impossible c'est déjà
une première seconde partie de la
solution et surtout être heureux à mon
sens depuis c'est vraiment se
réapproprier une réalité en se posant
cette question là parce que ce qui fait
souffrir c'est rarement la situation
vrai tel quel dans laquelle on est
plongé
c'est le fait qu'on la subissent comme
n'ai pas choisi que d'acteurs ont soit
devenu spectateur de sa vie et accepter
la réalité c'est pas accepter la réalité
d'un bloc telle qu'elle est c'est
accepter une donnée de base que l'on va
transformer que l'on va travailler au
corps pour arriver à quelque chose qui
nous satisfasse intérieurement c'est
accepter comme on le disait tout à
l'heure des tracteurs dans un scénario
dont on n'a pas forcément choisi le
script qui va être parfois une comédie
parfois une tragédie mais qu'on peut
incarner et qu'on peut transformer alors
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que notre
civilisation a tendance à vouloir nous
préserver de toute douleur on nous vend
des assurances des médicaments on nous
entoure de mousse peut-être à tort c'est
vrai que prendre des coups cicatriser
faire une peau nouvelle plus forte
c'est aussi un apprentissage de la vie
quand on a été au sol et quand on s'est
relevé on tolère plus les patrons
abusifs les relations toxiques les
mensonges et voie de garage
professionnelle ou à steam finalement on
a une démarche plus assuré et on évite
certains certaines choses qui rendent
très malheureux aussi dans l'existence
on a tendance à plaindre ceux qui ont
souffert ou à critiquer ceux qui se sont
trompés de voie mais l'arbuste qui
pousse toujours aidé d'un tuteur va
tomber au premier orage
en revanche celui qui aura été exposé au
vent à la pluie à la sécheresse pouce
droit
ça vous pouvez vous dire c'est solide et
finalement tout ce que j'ai fait c'est
pas si exceptionnel
j'ai pas grand chose d'exceptionnel si
je les fais c'est qu'on peut tous le
faire
la seule chose c'est da continuer à
cesser d'avoir peur de l'orage
voilà merci